Uber
Uber’s meteoric rise to dominate the personal
transport market has made it one of the most
successful - and the most hated - companies
in history.
Along with its controversial CEO Travis Kalanick,
it has developed a reputation as being iron-fisted,
cruel and relentless in its pursuit of power.
Inspiring an equal measure of admiration and
loathing, Uber has turned the traditional
taxi industry on its head - and provided consumers
with a more user friendly way of getting from
Point A to point B.
Genesis
In the mid-1990’s, with the world Wide Web
still in its infancy, the undergraduate Computer
Science Association or USCA at UCLA University
in sunny California was a breeding ground
for future millionaires.
The association was more of a clubhouse where
like-minded students could relax after class
while they played games and talked computers.
Though not a founding member, a young San
Fernando Valley resident by the name of Travis
Kalanick soon become a central figure of this
group.
Kalanick was pursuing a double major in computers
and business.
Despite the boom in Internet companies up
north in Silicon Valley, the USCA was mostly
about fun and games.
Soon, however its members stumbled upon an
opportunity.
Because there were no firewalls back then,
it was possible to search for files on all
connected computers and then index the results.
The group decided to replicate the time honoured
practice of college kids lending out their
record albums.
But they were able to extend the lending fraternity
to anybody who was connected to the internet.
The idea was molded into a start up which
they named Scour.
It was a tool that would scrub a network’s
files looking for MP3s.
Travis Kalanick was not involved in the founding
of Scour because he was doing an internship
with Intel.
But as Scour became established and grew in
popularity, he jumped on board.
He was in charge of marketing and fund-raising.
It was in this role that Kalanick developed
the on the job training that would serve him
in later years.
Living at his parents’ house he would spend
up to 8 hours a day on the phone, wheeling
and dealing to attract investors.
In 1999, his efforts paid off when Hollywood
power player Michael Ovitz poured $4 million
into Scour in return for a 51% share in the
company.
Within a year, however, the writing was on
the wall for Scour.
It’s success had attracted a competitor
who would do things better - Napster.
Scour's fundamental problem was that it didn’t
scale.
The site would often crash through overuse,
and Scour was running out of fresh content.
Meanwhile Napster was paying close attention
to Scour’s problems.
They introduced a tweak whereby listening
to a song would automatically make it available
to others.
As a result Napster quickly became a viral
sensation.
Scour tried to gain ground by moving into
sharing movie files, but ultimately they were
doomed.
They company went into bankruptcy in 2000.
Red Swoosh
By the end of that year, with Scour gone,
twenty-four year old Travis Kalanick, had
no college degree and no job.
He needed a new plan - and he needed it fast.
Within weeks of the folding of Scour, Kalanick
was onto his next project.
He teamed with former Scour partner Michael
Todd to form Red Swoosh, which was essentially
Scour recreated for business customers.
This new startup would allow companies to
use the Internet to share similarly large
files with their customers.
Enabling large file movement was already big
business, but Red Swoosh’s competitive advantage
was that it capitalized on the asset light
strategy to keep its costs below that of competitors.
Red Swoosh pushed and pulled files from personal
computers owned by others, foreshadowing what
Uber would later do in connecting riders with
drivers whose cars represented ‘massive
unused capital’ on city streets.
As CEO of Red Swoosh, Kalanick’s job was
to pitch to potential clients.
As he had done at Scour, he set a frenetic
work pace, proving to be the quintessential
workaholic.
Despite his gargantuan efforts, however, Red
Swoosh, became a victim of the peaking of
the Internet bubble.
Investments dried up and tensions rose.
Kalanick blamed Todd for mismanagement and
wrangled for him to be kicked out of the company.
Kalanick kept wheeling and it looked as if
he had found a saviour.
On September 11th, 2001 he was scheduled to
meet with a potential partner investor named
Danny Lewin.
Lewin, however, was on board American Airlines
Flight 11 from Boston to Los Angeles, which
crashed into the north tower of the World
Trade Center.
It is thought that he was the first to die,
after confronting the hijackers.
By the end of 2001, Red Swoosh was out of
money.
Reprieve came in the form of a father and
son team who had made a fortune from a semiconductor
business - James and Jared Chao.
They agreed to pour $300,000 into the business
in return for a 30% stake.
Over the next few years, Red Swoosh stumbled
along, propped up by further investment.
Then, in April 2007, major competitor Akamai
purchased the company, hiring the handful
of employees of the company, including Kalanick.
Kalanick was now 31 years old.
For his share in the sale of Red Swoosh he
had pocketed around $3 million.
Yet, he was now tied to a large corporation
as an employee - something he had never experienced
before.
Over the next year he worked to continue building
the Red Swoosh brand.
At the same time he re-styled himself as an
‘angel investor’ for young entrepreneurs.
He bought an old house in the Castro, an old
San Francisco neighborhood and named it the
‘Jam Pad.’
The house became a meeting place for this
with fresh tech based ideas and no money.
Kalanick revelled in the role of wiser, older
sage who had been there and done that.
His blog, which he called Swooshing, became
essential reading.
In it he described his home, the Jam Pad as
‘ a place where entrepreneurs regularly
come to hang out, to rap on ideas, to jam
with other entrepreneurs, to play Wii Tennis
and Gears of War and to have fantastic healthy
gourmet meals made by the Jam Pad’s in-house
chef.’
Kalanick quit Red Swoosh in late 2008.
He spent the next couple of years biding his
time as he examined new business ventures.
He also threw himself into leisure activities.
He became a part of a group called the Random
Travellers Society.
They would randomly spin a globe to decide
where in the world they would travel.
In 2010, Kalanick got heavily involved with
a Q and A website called Formspring.
He invested in the company, but was soon running
the show.
At the same time, he was still looking out
for other opportunities.
He was introduced to a smartphone app started
by an old friend named Garrett Camp.
The app was called UberCab and it allowed
the user to make quick contact with a limousine
in the San Francisco area.
Kalanick began sharing his time between Formspring
and UberCab.
Within a few months it became obvious that
he had to choose between them.
The people at Formspring were pushing him
to become their CEO, but in late September,
2010 he walked into a board meeting and declared,
“I’m going to be Uber.”
Uber Begins
In the Summer of 2008, Garrett Camp, a mild
mannered Canadian software designer was waiting
for a cab in San Francisco’s bay area.
He’d been waiting nearly thirty minutes
for a cab that had promised to be there in
fifteen.
When he saw an empty cab from a competitor
company come by he hailed it and got in.
A few minutes later, though, he got a call
from the original taxi company asking where
he was.
He replied that they were late so he’d gotten
in another cab.
This became a regular occurrence for Camp.
Eventually both taxi companies that he dealt
with, Luxor and Yellow, blacklisted him.
This annoyed the young Canadian, who just
happened to have $75 million in his bank account
after selling his first start-up, StumbleUpon.
Hailing a cab was now more difficult for Camp.
The taxi switchboard companies would cut him
off as soon as they saw his number.
One evening, while standing on a street corner
and running late for a date, he had the proverbial
light bulb moment.
He had his brand new Apple iPhone in his hand.
That iPhone was GPS enabled.
Why couldn’t he request a cab directly from
his phone, simply by pushing a button that
says ‘Pick Me Up’?
This way you cut out the dispatcher completely.
Camp also knew that the iPhone included a
thing called an accelerometer.
This would allow for the tracking of not just
where a car was but how fast it was moving.
With this technology, a map could be generated
that showed the beginning and end of the trip,
along with its duration and price.
It would also link the rider with the driver
- cutting out the middleman.
On August 8th, 2008 Camp paid $35 to reserve
the website, www.ubercab.com.
He then began to elicit feedback about his
idea from his circle of entrepreneurial friends.
He also interviewed taxi drivers, who complained
about the hours they were sitting idly waiting
for a fare.
Slowly other people began jumping on board.
One of them was Travis Kalanick.
In early 2009, Travis contributed an idea
that became pivotal to the future Uber model.
Rather than buying a fleet of vehicles, which
Camp was envisioning, Kalanick told him that
he didn’t need to buy cars - just give the
app to drivers and let then be free agents.
They would work when they wanted to work.
The focus for both men was on limousine rides,
rather than normal taxi cab rides.
Kalanick signed on as an advisor to Uber,
with a 10% stake in the company.
It took over a year to develop the app.
By January, 2010 Camp and Kalanick began testing
the service.
They also began making plans to launch operations
in San Francisco.
Kalanick hired a 27-year-old General Electric
middle management employee named Ryan Graves
to oversee the San Francisco launch.
Graves began visiting garages to sign up limo
drivers.
The service launched in late May, 2010 with
just a handful of drivers and customers.
The initial customer base came from Twitter
followers who had been keeping tabs on what
the entrepreneurs were up to.
Kalanick and Graves who, had been made CEO,
began working together to find investors.
After receiving a lot of knockbacks, the seed
funding round raised $1.25 million.
It was at this point that Kalanick decided
to go full time with UberCab.
But he wasn't content to play second fiddle
to a guy that he had hired.
He orchestrated a demotion for Graves and
claimed the title of CEO for himself.
He also demanded that his shareholding rise
from 10% to 23%.
On the very day that Kalanick became CEO,
the company received a cease and desist letter
from the San Francisco Metro Transit Authority
and California Public Utilities Commission.
It stated that the name ‘UberCab’ meant
that they were a taxicab company and under
the authority’s direction.
Kalanick solved the problem in 5 seconds.
He changed the name from UberCab to simply
Uber.
At the time of his taking over, the operation
was tiny - and it made plenty of mistakes.
On Halloween of 2010, they offered a discount
to riders.
This created such a huge demand, on their
already busiest day yet, that it left a lot
of people unable to get a ride.
Despite this, growth was steady throughout
2010.
Then, over the 2011 New Year period it absolutely
blew up.
Word of mouth was responsible for the exponential
growth in Uber’s customer base.
But finding Limo drivers was a different story.
They didn’t have the same social media habits
as the young about towner’s in need of a
limo ride.
Only licensed drivers were eligible to drive
for Uber.
They all had customers of their own and none
of them were prepared to go exclusive with
Uber.
Uber began giving away iPhones preloaded with
the Uber app to drivers.
This enabled them to increase their driver
supply to keep up with the ever growing demand
in San Francisco.
Having proven the model in Frisco, Kalanick
started to replicate it in other cities.
Under the guidance of head of operations,
Ryan Graves, they turned their attention on
Seattle, Chicago, Boston, and Washington,
D.C.
In each city, Graves made connections in the
tech world fist.
This created buzz and attracted cutting edge
users.
Once the word was being generated, they began
looking for drivers and working through government
regulations.
As they moved from city to city, the Uber
team began refining their playbook, refining
the system and making it more efficient.
The process became (1) establish buzz in the
tech community (2) assess regulations (3)
recruit drivers (4) develop pricing (5) woo
local media, and (6) capitalize with social
media buzz.
In the early days, Kalanick was a master at
local public relations.
Promotion would start with a blog post, in
which he would relate how much he loved the
city they were moving into.
He would highlight its key attributes and
then talked about how much greater the city
would be when Uber had introduced their service.
By 2011, the job of securing investment was
much easier.
In February Benchmark Capital poured $10 million
into the company.
At this point Uber was valued at $60 million.
The company had nine thousand customers and
$1.8 million in net revenue.
It was estimated that it would get to $100
million gross revenue within a year.
It achieved that goal in six months.
Enemies Emerge
As Uber sprang up in more and more cities
across America, it began to receive push-back.
The sixth city that they went into was Washington,
D.C.
Before they could get off the ground, however,
the city’s taxi commissioner announced that
Uber was operating an illegal taxi operation.
On Martin Luther King Day, 2011 the commissioner
ordered an Uber which took him to a press
conference at the Mayflower Hotel.
He then proceeded to impound the driver’s
car and issued a $20,000 ticket.
But Uber didn’t back down.
They assured all drivers that they would pay
all of their fines and took the moral high
ground in public, asserting that they were
not a taxi company and, therefore, not subject
to regulatory provisions.
In one city after another, taxi companies,
the taxi commission and local and state agencies
came at Uber to shut it down.
Under the guidance of consultant Bradley Tusk,
Uber fought back.
They ran social media campaigns to stop the
opposers, often meeting them in court.
The public were overwhelmingly on the side
of the company.
But there was one thing that Uber’s customers
were not happy about.
During busy periods, such as rush hour and
bar closing times, it would apply ‘surge
pricing’ with rates going up during these
peak demand times.
Surge pricing had the effect of encouraging
more drivers to work and encouraging some
customers to find a cheaper service.
Both of these results eased demand on the
service.
But it also infuriated the customer base.
Many of them blamed the unfairness of surge
pricing at the foot of CEO Kalanick, who quickly
became known as a cutthroat businessman who
refused to listen to consumer sentiment.
By the end of 2012, Uber was operating in
27 locations.
In that year they also introduced UberX, providing
rides in hybrid cars.
But it was also the year that Uber faced its
first serious competition.
It came in San Francisco from a young company
called Lyft.
Lyft was a ride sharing business whereby a
person would slap a large pink moustache on
the grill of their car and then pick up those
who were in need of a ride for the shared
cost of gas and a little extra donation.
Usually this would work out to be less than
a cab fare for the same distance.
It used a smartphone app that was modelled
off of the Uber app.
Lyft was a hit with young people, who preferrred
its friendlier, more laid back image.
Riding in a limo was starting to look elitist.
As a result, Uber set about restructuring
its game plan.
It would rebrand itself with a focus on getting
a rider from Point A to Point as quickly and
as inexpensively as possible.
UberX, which had started out as an eco-friendly
alternative to a limo, became the means of
beating traditional taxi services.
In early 2014, Kalanick hired former Amazon
executive Jeff Holden as product development
manager.
Holdren identified two things he found lacking
in the Uber system; the ability of the rider
to communicate beforehand where he wanted
to go and the driver’s ability to navigate
there.
He oversaw two new features to fix this - destination
input by the rider and turn-by-turn navigation
on the driver app.
Both features were a hit and by the end of
2014 Uber was operating in 262 markets worldwide.
Uber was by now a genuine phenomenon.
But it was a phenomenon that had attracted
a lot of enemies.
A lot of that animosity was thanks to the
brash nature of CEO Travis Kalanick.
His outspokenness and inability to hold his
tongue soon made him the offender in chief.
Kalanick was the poster boy for political
incorrectness, once stating that he could
land women as quickly as a person could summon
an Uber.
Kalanick’s divisive personality ony underscored
Uber’s growing reputation as a bully in
the marketplace.
Reports were publicized of some underhanded
tactics used to undermine competitor Lyft.
Publications began labelling Uber as an evil
company and describing its CEO as an ‘Ayn
Rand loving libertarian nut job.’
In some cities it become politically correct
to avoid Uber all together.
Uber was in a strange position.
Worldwide its business was growing from strength
to strength.
At the same time, however, its reputation
was tanking.
Things went from bad to abysmal when an Uber
driver in Delhi was convicted of raping a
passenger.
Something had to be done - quick.
In early 2015, Uber brought in a new executive
to oversee digital and physical safety, Joe
Sullivan.
He had a long to-do list, including stricter
management of driver activity.
Things were tightened up to the extent that
Uber management can tell if a driver is holding
his phone while driving or braking too hard
or going too fast.
During that year another new executive, Sally
Kay set about taking and, and overcoming,
a slew of local regulators who were intent
on stopping Uber in its tracks.
By the beginning of 2016, Uber was on a more
even keel.
Rather than lurching from one crisis to another.
In an attempt to change its image, the company
teamed with Mothers Against Drunk Driving
to encourage young people to take an Uber
rather than drink and drive.
It also partnered with hospitals to make it
cheaper for cancer patients to return home
from treatment.
The Driverless Future
Travis Kalanick has been working on introducing
driverless cars to the Uber mix since 2013.
He loved the idea that it would no longer
rely on that most uncontrollable of business
variables - people.
Autonomous vehicles would be far safer as
robots are not subject to drowsiness or distraction.
And robots would be cheaper than people.
But in 2013, the technology wasn’t yet ready.
By February 2014, Uber was canvassing the
world looking for top robotics talent.
It purchased a Pittsburg company called Carnegie
Robotics, making it the kernel of its self-driving
car team.
Then, in December 2014, Uber hired 60 researchers
from the National Robotics Engineering center.
After two years of development, Uber announced
in August 2016, that its cars were ready for
a limited showing.
The cars worked but still required a human
engineer behind a steering wheel should something
go wrong.
Uber are still working on their driverless
car.
In that quest they are in a race with the
likes of Google, Apple and Tesla, which is
rumoured to be considering its own ride sharing
business.
All of this competition will, ultimately,
result in a better, cheaper service for those
of us wanting to get from Point A to Point
B as efficiently
and cost effectively as possible.